يوصل المنتخب المغربي لكره القدم تدريباته
على ملعب عبد الله بن خليفه نادي الدحيل
وذلك عقب وصوله الى الدوحه ويستهلوا
المنتخب المغربي
منتخب بلجيكا في السابع والعشرين من هذا
الشهر وكندا في الاول من ديسمبر
الاستعدادات والاجواء يؤكد اللاعبون انها
جيدا وسيرتلون قصار جهدهم من اجل تصريف
بلادهم وتمثيل المغرب على احسن وجهه الحمد
لله اليوم
قاعدين وجد ان شاء الله للمقابله الاولى
اللي هي تكون اسيمه
الجروب عازم بس يحقق ان شاء الله الفوز
بالمجموعه ولا نهتموا الان بشان الفريق
الذي سانواجهه علينا ان نساعد جيدا فنحن
لدينا لاعبون رائعون وان شاء الله سنكون
في المستوى
ان شاء الله
الى الامارات يوم غد الخميس لخوض اللقاء
الوديه امام المنتخب جورجيا في الشارقه
الاماراتيه ثم العوده الى الدوحه لاستكمال
الاستعداد للمباراه الاولى امام كرواتيا
يوم الاربعاء المقبل
[تصفيق]